hair long hair long now me review me
review men review me review sigh remix
that and make it into like a hip-hop
single thank you main review review look
at this centered shot
look at this professionalism look at
this camera quality you can see the hair
so my shirt if that's not quality I
don't know what is what am I talking
about I'm talking about means you guys
you kids like memes
I got means I got some memes Hey look at
this Earth gravitational pull no you
can't just launch object in space engine
human engineers haha rocket goes but
that's true because Rockets do make that
sound I understand this joke I'm just
like you kids did you guys see the
SpaceX launch pretty epic finally some
good news
let's check it out
people were quick to point out however a
few similarities it's finally happening
Star Wars live adaptation when
everything is going wrong in America but
it leaves there's a rocket launch at
least we had those ten minutes of pure
bliss Flat Earth the nurse btfo okay
look at that what what's that
edited footage obviously SpaceX
astronauts leaving America is everything
I wouldn't mind being an astronaut right
now the world falling apart
SpaceX astronaut adios adios amigos why
should we go to space we have everything
we need here on earth the earth be like
SpaceX we're going to postpone the take
up the two astronauts who's been waiting
for hours I think they waited a little
bit more than that I'm sure they could
wait apparently got delayed yeah and one
of those suits are comfortable they look
interesting don't blink you I saw this
so annoying I wanted to see the landing
the connection went out they're like oh
it landed I'm like come on dude rocket
in 1969 I can get hit by lightning
during ascent and still complete my
mission rockets in 2020 help there's a
cloud I can't love Oh No stinky clouds I
mean obviously they need good weather
conditions they're not gonna risk a
billion dollar I don't know how much it
cost project for some clouds Tony Stark
Neil Armstrong ill and most are you
saying that they are penetrating Ilyn
musk I don't see I don't want to see
that no nevermind but that's not the
only good news for Elon Musk even much
also as you know probably named his
child congratulations first on your
newborn x aa-12 how Ilyn musk son XA a
twelve sons when he's fall down the
stairs
no he goes haha exit on goes get it
imagine being a mean before you're even
born goddamn alright SpaceX memes gets a
solid three thank God for something else
happening can something happen can we
get some good memes I I didn't want to
point this out but I think it's pretty
clear lack of a meme review videos
equals lack of memes lack of clapping
seriously that's been so few means
lately the best one I think is for sure
is that the buff dog meme which is
basically a combination of beta and Chad
meme combined with the haha goes bitter
just two simple things contrasting each
other I don't know why I'm explaining
the meme it's so [ __ ] obnoxious
anyway rejected people in 2012 I would
go to the gym and improve my personality
to make my crush fall for me reject
people in 2020 I am the best I'm gonna
make a meme right now you can do both
it's possible hey guys stop looking down
on my bro he's a good boy as well no
well that's a Chad thing bro supporting
Bros good on you doggy
meemers then hey look at this funny
drawing I think this should draw this
somewhere too meemers now no it's
another thing I don't like me with good
versus bad yeah for those of you don't
know Kilroy Was here with someone of the
first graffitis that was a that was ever
made and it was literally I think it was
originated from soldiers but then people
started appropriating it and writing it
everywhere so it got really confusing
like who is Kilroy and why is he
everywhere
good times horror then I hunt and kill
people in their dreams horror now haha
head goes we told you I told you their
combined why do I like this meme
teachers in normal classes stop talking
teachers now please guys say something
say something
cringe teachers beta teachers Japanese
gamers then I would breeze through these
kaizo mario levels touch impossible
danmaku from these STDs and beat these
guys
in fighters with my combos gamers now
I've spent over 330 thousand yen and I
still didn't get my wife my you can you
can basically make this meme into before
good now banned how about time you kids
are boomers huh I didn't know you had it
in ya huh I love this one I don't know
who made it so many plans let's go Jun
already I feel like I did nothing
yeah I think that goes for everyone I
think that goes for everyone can this
year be over please men 30,000 BCE okay
here we go again old good new band
this is goddess of fertility I worship
her as she represents everything that is
beautiful in this world men 2020
Lamar shame is that a mother flipping
12-pack god damn people keep thinking my
my workout goal is Jojo but now it's
buff dodge and nothing else you may not
like it but that's what people physical
Ike that's what I inspire no P P P P so
big it can retract inside body that's
how it goes and back then I want you for
you as army ads now if you play the game
it will come and they'll provide Jenkins
and your mama or knock on your door in
0.6 what do you do press X to continue
pirates 300 years ago I will kill you
and drink wine from your skull pirates
date haha I download free games come on
that's not the beta version come on come
on guys come on they're both Chad's
they're both chance my dad I devoured
every part of chicken me
there's leaf in myself why teachers
hundred years ago if you don't do what I
say little [ __ ] I'll hit you with a
ruler teachers now no T teachers in my
day I remember we had those what are
they called there was like a transparent
paper I'm sure a lot of people relate to
this and you put her over this mirror
light that reflected it on the wall it's
like a cheap projector but they would
always like oh I remember my teacher
freaked that one day cuz she couldn't
figure out how to place it on the
it gets mirrored because of the mirror
youtubers around 2010 I'd like to share
my passion with people online no matter
how many views my videos get you to
person is this a personal attack or
something huh prank gone sexual 18 plus
free iPhone X giveaway fortnight ninja
quit that's the title of this video
right here 3 V bucks
haha 18 plus oh yeah baby
hey another ripping on journalist
soprano a journalist in the 1950s the
Mafia might kill me but I'll follow the
story anyways journalist now some gamer
comfy gay I need vacation one month
please I killed the Mafia okay these are
all the Joker's I kill them off your
boss and stole his wife okay I'm the
most dangerous terrorist okay got it
and the biggest drug lord in the city
have millions Lamborghinis okay got it
mom the TV is being made to me joke it
really is a representation of society
society he said the word reporters again
Jesus Christ I will bring the gangs
crimes to light even if it risk my life
oh my god Carly he changed her trance
yeah
reported this back in the day definitely
did not report on any [ __ ] you're
right I do not remember hearing about
Britney Spears every [ __ ] day Nass
that back in the day we said men to the
moon with a week spc legit it's so
impressive how they send people to the
moon when the computers are we're so
simple it's amazing NASA today please
give us a ride
come on alert can we come - can we come
with you're alone I have just sacked the
city of Rome costs 410 AD costs today
I love Evanescence hey let's bring back
a man SS all right I don't care if it's
cringe it's flippin good
I like it I don't care what people say
no one can tell me different Evanescence
is popping people then people now wait
what is this place gems what lamzy
format how do we get out of here yeah
there it is everyone named samurais now
it's ruined
sex wait there's more
Samus is woman that's so cool a DS
gamers I wish to be with set on my face
gamers today how about that
come on both for these are Chad Don come
on ok that's it next name guys I have a
siren head name remember siren head I
haven't I would actually reviewed it the
teachers copy what you get get it can
someone can we bring back memes
hey remember memes when that was funny
remember that ok ok I got I got you I
got you
I think what we're all asking right now
is what the hell is Harrison Ford
Harrison Ford feels like a guy that's so
cool so he's like I'm gonna all right
guys I'm gonna do something different
this this is how you wear a mask and
still look cool I I figured it out guys
no it didn't tickle your funny bone
alright how about this how about this me
sleeping suddenly my body they say you
can't physically feel a gift but I came
I can and yes I call it gif and no one
can tell me otherwise god damn
I feel like smash like subscribe if you
felt it too
okay hey look it's not me meme America
slowly becoming a third world country as
we get deeper in the 20/20 its evolving
just backwards I don't know why this is
a meme
I see this all the time to review this
means to kill it because it doesn't make
sense
it's called evolving it's a word Felix
don't make me miss out of my ineptitude
goddammit
hey look guys I have an official know
your mean page god I hate this page it's
so hard to navigate all right let's see
the funniest ones I don't even get it
what the hell it's evolving just
backwards
perhaps humans have regressed over the
years nice nice yes yes yes yes oh god I
got the hiccup again memes I used to
laugh at ordered a 10-piece chicken
McNuggets
got 11 memes I laugh at now hallo friend
you may access the cubes it is evolving
backwards
can we bring back 2012 means we need to
do something guys I think Joe has
ligament what's Joe whose leg my leg
mama Joe my life that I'm all all right
okay true you can't deny it science and
facts high-tech robot at Russia forum
turns out to be man in suit it's
developing just backwards there you have
it airports carrying strap yeah yeah we
fixed that it's almost like they had a
function huh how about that Wow
alright zero gets their rope boom stop
it stop making memes in this I don't
like it Mark's got a big brain meme
that's funny I get bad me bad meme shame
shame Tambourine of [ __ ]
I feel my heart crack Hey look at the
hair look at hair look at this it's
evolving just upwards how about that
kids
you like that kids ruining my means the
people in movies based of true stories
the actual fish it's funny because true
see that was a little fun little mean
template for you guys how about that
2020 outfits okay we got January is that
the area 51 radar I can't remember
oh no it was World War two yeah February
all the fires right I don't remember
mark March I think we all know April
quarantine and May riots great Oh God
just one month just one month please
that's all I need
I just a [ __ ] in the woods okay all
right oh I forgot a dodge mean real
meemers people creating new meme trends
can write original jokes has the peepee
of a cent hour is it sent our people who
okay let me read it goddamnit people who
repost the same jokes needs real meemers
to make new memes uses the same jokes
over again small peepee small are your
wedding son yes Ted I'm making a meta
meme about memes making memes thinking
about memes and I'm pretty sure this is
what they want to see are you winning
sir
I forgot to review that mean that's a
funny meme how about that bonus meme
hate the temporary haha my heart it
cracked tambourine is on undergoing
surgery she's gonna be fine one like
equals one prayer are your wedding son
please play with my bridge and
yeah I'm winning dad I'm winning big
times in plural yeah are you're winning
son no dad I'm not winning I don't even
play games anymore they're not fun I
just sit and scroll Twitter endlessly
for hours quick Twitter gets whoa
come on gamers gamers are winning son
having a great time things did that's
great to hear love you son unexpected
made me laugh threw a curve ball well
done are you winning son dad I won we're
so proud of your son we made spaghetti
and meatballs to celebrate the [ __ ] is
this are you winning son I generally I
don't know why it's so sweet in that way
with parents coming in are you winning
are you winning son yes yes I'm winning
that got them I'm looking at PewDiePie
is 500 threaded video dad of course I'm
winning I'm winning big time more than
you ever did don't ever look me in the
eye you scoundrel
I'm ashamed my DNA came from yours now
leave my broom and cook me some goddamn
meatballs are you winning son this much
pretty much summarizes it thank you for
watching me review the most esteemed
mean show on the planet
we have guests like blue shirt kid
subscribe become a member
we're gonna do live streams thanks for
all the members so far preciate you this
month we raised twenty nine thousand six
hundred and sixty five thousand pounds
to charity all the money from members is
gonna go to Winston's wish which is a
great charity that helps kids get help
after losing a parent or sibling it's a
great charity thank you everyone
we're gonna do a different charity next
month so do let me know if you have any
suggestions and what we can support I
know it's a crazy world out there right
now and I'm sure we can make some
difference that's it
meme out brofist
how about there's a cool
[Music]
[Applause]